على الرغم من أننا نسمع من
مصادر عسكرية أوكرانية يقولون إن
بوتين يزيد أه من عدد
حاملات صواريخ كروز في البحر الأسود
إلى ثلاث من الواضح الآن أن صواريخ كروز الإمداد الخاصة بهم
قد سقطت
بشكل كبير ، ولديهم إمدادات إيرانية
قادمة الآن عبر
الإنترنت ولكن  لكن هذا يعني أنك تعرف حقًا
مضاعفة قدرتها على الإطلاق ثلاث مرات
من البحر الأسود ، ما الذي يعنيه هذا
بالنسبة للحرب
بشكل كبير عندما أنظر إلى هذا ،
أنظر إلى البحر الأسود والبحر الأسود
هو مجرد حوض استحمام لا مكان
للاختباء فيه.  في البحر الأسود وهناك
مخرج واحد فقط ، وهناك
مدخل واحد فقط ، لذا فما تفعله روسيا هناك
ما تفعله الولايات المتحدة هناك
وبصراحة لهذا السبب
لا يوجد للولايات المتحدة حاليًا وجود كبير
في البحر الأسود.  لا
تحب البحرية الذهاب إلى هناك لهذا السبب بالذات الذي
يجعل روسيا تزيد من تواجدها
بعيدًا عن المنطق في ذهني لأنه
يزيد من ملف المخاطر
لديهم ويمكنهم إطلاق cr  الصواريخ التي تستخدم من
بحر قزوين ، ستستغرق
وقتًا أطول قليلاً ، ولا تقلل من الدقة ،
لكنني لا أفهم سبب
قيامهم بذلك ، وبالمناسبة
، كان لدى الأوكرانيين سجل جيد جدًا في
متابعة تلك  التواجد في
البحر الأسود اعتمادًا على
مكانه الصحيح ، تذكر موسكو
وبالطبع أه مؤخرًا الجسر أه
جسر الخرطوشة حسنًا ، شكرًا
جزيلاً عام كما هو الحال دائمًا أنا أقدر
لك